où
on
astrologie et nature
les 12 signes du zodiaque
oh
notre galaxie notre voie lactée ne
constituent que l'infime partie d'un
océan spatiale littéralement sans limite
nous observons cette infinie de notre
petite planète privilégié d'alors que la
nature et a permis l'apparition de mille
et une formes de vie
des formes de vie hautement sophistiqué
il n'est pas un composant de notre terre
même parmi ceux qui paraissent les plus
arides qu'ils ne soient peuplés
d'organismes vivants
oh
nous le devons essentiellement au soleil
qui procure chaleur et lumière à notre
planète
la surface de la terre s'est depuis
longtemps refroidi même si un feu
intense continue de brasser en son
centre de la 20 qu'en descente
les éléments au fil des millénaires se
sont nettement dissocier
les terres ont surnagé dominant les
océans la matière à l'état liquide
le tout baigne dans une atmosphère
gazeuse une planète quatre éléments
sur terre leur contact peut provoquer
des réactions
le feu entraîne ainsi un phénomène de
combustion
chaque étape de la vie s'alimente de
réactions chimiques créatrice d'énergie
ses différentes composantes de la vie
terrestre se reflète dans les 12 signes
du zodiaque astrologique clairement
images et ainsi le capricorne est signe
de terre le bélier et signe de feu le
cancer est signe d'eau les gémeaux son
signe d'air chacun trouve sa traduction
en termes de caractère humain
le signe de terre correspondent à un
tempérament volontaire inébranlable le
signe de feu traduit un caractère
passionné excessif le signe d'eau
symbolise une personnalité émotive et
indécise
le signe des rangs fin se rattache aux
natures fantasque
la terre tourne autour du soleil suivant
un plan circulaire
appelez-le éclectique autour de lui des
fils le zodiac des signes il ne faut
cependant pas le confondre avec le
cercle des constellations regroupement
image et de certaines étoiles comme ici
le sagittaire et le scorpion
ils portent effectivement le même nom
que certains signes du zodiaque les
poissons
le lion
le cancer
ou la balance ces désignations sont
symboliques
à l'opposé des constellations les signes
du zodiaque sont tous de même taille
il divise le ciel en deux segments de
30° chacun sait le point d'intersection
de l'écliptique avec l'équateur céleste
ce qu'on appelle le point vernal qui
sert d'origine au calcul astrologique
il marque l'entrée du soleil dans le
signe du bélier lors de l'équinoxe de
printemps
mais l' axe de rotation de la terre
n'étant pas fixe l'équinoxe recul d'un
signe zodiacal tous les deux mille cent
soixante ans par rapport aux
constellations
à présent le bélier se trouve au degré
zéro entre poissons et verso
les quatre début de saison marc des
passages de l'orbité terrestre autour du
soleil quand le soleil se trouve à la
verticale du tropique donc au début de
notre été il se trouve au début du signe
zodiacal du cancer
le capricorne c'est le début de l'hiver
dans l'hémisphère nord
quand le soleil se trouve à la verticale
de l'équateur c'est le début du
printemps ou de l'automne le soleil
entre dans le bélier ou la balance au
commencement de ces quatre signes
correspondent les quatre points
cardinaux
selon qu'ils débutent poursuit ou achève
une saison le signe présente une
dynamique particulière chaque élément
sur terre répond à des caractéristiques
précises que l'on peut mettre en
parallèle avec les caractères humains le
signe qui commence une saison est
appelée cardinal il implique un désir de
marche en avant dans la nature l'eau
courante est associée au principe
cardinal en termes astrologique les
signes qui développe la saison sont
qualifiés le fixe il marque une volonté
d' équilibre
la terre dans son stade de fertilité se
rattache à ce principe
le troisième de ces mouvements ternaire
qui marque le changement de saison est
appelée mutable il est typique des
caractères mobiles rapides
adaptable en perpétuelle mutation
cette flexibilité est commune aux
gémeaux signe d' air et eau s'agit d'air
signe de feu qui se trouve en vis-à-vis
sur le zodiaque le souffle qu'engendrent
les gémeaux propulsés dans l'espace
les étincelles de vie qui anime le
sagittaire chacun des quatre éléments
peut donc se manifester dans les trois
différents mouvements ternaire pour
former au total les douze signes qui
constitue le zodiaque le bélier est un
signe cardinal son élément et le feu on
l'a dit le mouvement cardinal indique le
désir d'une marche en avant
rectiligne ascensionnel comme celle
d'une flamme
c'est le feu qui pétillent éclate et se
propage
et
la flamme peut s'épuiser lorsque la
substance est consumé mais la chaleur
continue à pousser l'air vers le haut
les matériaux mort régénère la matière
vivante suivant un perpétuel processus
de réaction et de combustion lavisse
alimente ainsi de la flamme et se
rattachent à l'élément feu
au début du printemps les pouces
jaillissent les bourgeons éclater la
nature entame un nouveau cycle de vie
c'est le temps de l'action de la
conquête de la renaissance à force de
vigueur et d'audace avec la volonté de
triompher le bélier déborde d'élan vital
c'est un précurseur un créateur le
bélier est gouverné par la planète mars
la planète rouge symbole de la force
guerrière
voici son cheminement dans le ciel
et
dans l'antiquité marc soares était le
dieu de la guerre évocateur du courage
militaire de l'audace et au delà de la
victoire et de la paix
il est évidemment associé au principe
même de la virilité gouverné par mars
le bélier et puis son exceptionnelle
robustesse est aussi une sexualité
exacerbée et impuissante instinct de
reproduction dans des cas extrêmes il
peut pour libérer son énergie se montrer
violent c'est le signe de l'exploit
physique de la détermination
si la lune se trouve dans le bélier le
lunaire s'en trouve dynamiser doté d'un
caractère indépendant et aventureux le
satellite terrestre la planète lune
régis à part entière un autre signe un
signe d' aux éléments passifs la lune
gouverne le cancer singh d'eau cardinal
c'est l'eau qui s'écoule l'eau courante
qui prend sa source dans la terre
perpétuellement en mouvement
serpentant au gré des caprices du sol
adaptant ses courbes et ses méandres aux
obstacles qu'elles rencontrent
on
la rivière réfléchit la lumière à son
image le cancer module ses émotions en
fonction des êtres qu'il côtoie été lieu
où il se fixe il creuse son sillon sans
notion du temps il est sensible réservé
et pudique parfois indolent
il
très attaché aux traditions et aux
coutumes
il puise ses motivations dans ces
sources familiales le cancer est
influençable sa nature le pouce
compromis tel les eaux destinées
irrésistiblement à se noyer dans l'océan
il refuse l'affrontement les agressions
extérieures
6 mars est dans le cancer la pulsion
maîtrise est moins forte dans ma nature
les plantes aquatiques s'adaptent à leur
environnement
si le courant se fait trop fort elle
cède se replie dans les profondeurs de
la rivière
à l'opposé du cancer si le dos on trouve
le capricorne principes solides par
excellence
le capricorne est le signe cardinal de
la terre dans ce qu'elle a de plus
riches en devenir c'est la terre d'hiver
celle qui recèle la semence mais aussi
la terre dans son apparence la plus rude
la plus froide
le capricorne est gouvernée par saturn
maître du temps que poursuit une
connotation négative une aura maléfique
mêmes macabre
dans les attributs symboliques liées au
corps humain le capricorne a hérité du
squelette référence apparemment sinistre
mais représentative avant tout de
fermeté de force et d'endurance
référence à ce calcaire qui bâtit aussi
des cathédrales d'éternité au coeur de
la terre
oui
compression de la matière en structure
solide qui croise insensiblement le
capricorne est bien ainsi mme cardinal
dissimulés à l'intérieur des druzes en
pleine obscurité des cristaux colorés et
transparent sous forme d'un
perceptiblement mais de manière
constante
il croise comme des êtres vivants
suivant un plan précis selon un modèle
préétabli
le corail éléments marins semble se
nourrir aussi de son environnement
liquide pareille aux sociétés humaines
il se bâtit sur ses propres ruine pour
créer au coeur de l'océan une terre
nouvelle
si la lune et dont le capricorne
l'élément liquide s'immobilise
l'acef des corps vivants se solidifie
l'eau impalpable se figeant structure de
classe
saturne retient les forces en action et
mars a toutes les peines du monde à s'y
opposer
il patiente et rassemble ses forces mars
dans le capricorne
c'est une nouvelle puissance motrice
assuré le finalement triompher la vie se
bat pour percer le sol selah sue vers la
lumière
la terre a beau tenté de réprimer le feu
de mars il éclate plus fort encore
d'avoir été longuement et freiner la
pression et la chaleur font jaillir des
entrailles de la terre des forces
tectoniques irrésistible mars s'élève
vers le ciel en projections de lave
incandescente
le feu réchauffe l'air et le propulse
vers le haut
c'est cette même puissance des flammes
qui anime la montgolfière dans son
irrésistible ascension
la balance signe d'air est aussi le
dernier signe cardinal
seiler agité l'air en mouvement et en
actions les ventes saisissent le ballon
le délivre de l'attraction terrestre
le vent souffle compense les différences
de pression harmonie et équilibre sont
aussi les caractéristiques de la balance
oh
dérobé à la pesanteur les créatures
aérienne semble détaché de toute
contrainte
sensible à la moindre vibration elles
vont à la rencontre des contraire être
de liaison en perpétuel état de va et
vient
on
le vent fléchit ce qu'il frôle
imprévisible tournoyant et fugitif
mon
c'est vénus symbole d'harmonie et de
beauté qui gouverne ce signe à son image
la balance professe le culte de l'
équilibre et un grand sens de
l'esthétique
le bélier influence venus avec la force
dynamisante de mars une emprise très
forte une énergie sans borne
une puissance pareille à celle dont
témoigne mars lorsque dans la nature
il stimule les vents pour les faire
souffrir tempête venus y perd au passage
beaucoup de ses vertus d'harmonie et
d'équilibré
outre la balance son domicile d'élection
est d'ailleurs un signe de terre la
terre du taureau le signe du calme et de
la solidité
le taureau actifs voisins dans le
zodiaque du bélier passif
l'animal symbolique représente en fait
toute la famille aussi bien le boeuf et
lavage que le taureau s'est par ailleurs
un signe fixe qui marque un grand désir
de stabilité c'est le symbole de la
terre nourricière la terre grasse et
féconde du printemps plein de chaleur et
de vie enracinement des plantes et
épanouissement de la nature en surface
une floraison qui fait flotter dans
l'air des parfums puissants une
atmosphère sensuelle bien propre à ce
taureau venus
oui
ce signe est symbole de jouissance ancré
dans le concret un mélange de joie et de
désir
st est tangible
vous
le soleil a animé les mouvements de la
terre il à favoriser la germination
là où le taureau sensuelle s'allie aux
principes liquide les déesses lune et
vénus peuvent déployer toute leur
influence féminine
m
l'eau stagnante et quant à elle
évocatrice de pourriture à l'opposé du
signe du taureau celui du scorpion est
le signe d'un fixe
sous la surface calme des eaux
tranquilles elle règne de la
décomposition de la pourriture les
étangs et les marécages sont scorpions
domaine des profondeurs ténébreuse des
mutations invisible des processus les
plus secrets de la nature
oh
beaucoup d'animaux sont irrésistiblement
attiré par les marais creuset d'une
nouvelle forme de vie foisonnante les
oeufs éclosent les têtards s'échappe
dans ces lieux privilégiés de la
transmutation de la transformation
ici n'est une bonne part de la chaîne
alimentaire animale
pluton gouverne le scorpion
pluton qui règne au royaume des morts
mais plutôt symbole aussi de
métamorphose et de rédemption
mars autres maîtres du cygne peu déployé
ici son énergie dévorante
ils y trouvent un aliment de choix pour
nourrir ses pulsions
ces franges sont en fait des réservoirs
de vie
les larves surgi de l'eau se transforme
dans libellules elles sèchent leurs
corps métamorphose est prête à une
existence nouvelle
elles ont parcouru un long chemin avant
d'émerger des eaux boueuses
là où la vie se manifeste venus
s'efforcent de déployer toutes ses
vertus le vert active la transformation
des substances en décomposition l'esprit
scorpions féconde la terre du taureau
ainsi scorpion est taureau à l'opposé
l'un de l'autre fournissent tous deux
aux fleurs la substance qui leur
permettra de s'épanouir
le soleil dont les rayons favorise des
compositions et éclosion pourriture et
floraison le soleil source d'énergie
noyau de notre système planétaire en
état de combustion permanente
le soleil qui gouverne le lion le signe
de feu fixe symbole de clarté et de
chaleur
ce principe essentiel de la vie
s'observe dans un simple feu de braise
sans que l'on puisse cependant il
décernait l'extrême complexité du
processus qui l'animent
ce processus tout organisme vivant le
porte en lui c'est un cycle permanent de
combustion parfaitement symbolisé par le
principe lyon au soleil
chaque plante chaque animal chaque
individu évite ainsi en analogie avec le
soleil
l'astrologie populaire désigne
d'ailleurs tous les hommes dont le
soleil participe à la naissance comme de
véritables lions être rayonnant qui
affirme leur joie d'exister
la puissance du soleil ne nous atteint
que forcément atténué en fait à
l'origine elle est excessive
redoutable et destructrice
aux antipodes de ce lion ravageur on
trouve le verso le sind heure fixe pour
autant que l'air puisse être qualifié de
fixe si ce n'est loin au dessus des
couches de nuages qui nous domine dans
l'ionosphère bien loin de notre espace
habité à 100 ou 500 km d'altitude
là où les particules échapper à la
pesanteur de la terre
ce monde lointain où l'air est
conducteur de l'électricité est sans
doute celui qui correspond le mieux au
verso
un monde où les tempêtes se forment et
concentrent leurs menaces
uranus régit le verso à vide d'absolu
l'électricité énergie lepointe moderne
et audacieuse
et
bon
là où s'établit une théorie là où se
développe une idée neuve règne uranus
si le soleil symbole de vie et de
puissance se trouve dans le verso
l'esprit maîtrisera la technique
uranus se passe pour favoriser en un
éclair dans notre esprit la création et
l'application de nouveaux instruments de
progrès
l'acce lyon verso privilégie la nouvelle
conquête de l'esprit scientifique
saturne régner seul sur le verso avant
la découverte relativement récente
d'uranus
l'un et l'autre se complète sans uranus
pas de révélations nouvelles sur notre
environnement
mais c'est saturn qui gère le chaos qui
permet de concrétiser les idées
abstraites soufflé par uranus
uranus n'en est pas moins le véritable
seigneur du verseau champion de la
persévérance dans la quête du savoir et
de ses applications
les signes des retendent
particulièrement à réaliser le plan
spirituel de l'homme c'est vrai pour la
balance le verso et les gémeaux les
gémeaux signe des remue table donc
préoccupés de mutation elle erre ici est
en perpétuel mouvement
c'est lui qui fait bruisser les feuilles
et claquer les portes les gémeaux
s'adapte aux circonstances
ils sont nerveux instinctif indépendant
parfois instable
ouais
ans
les gémeaux varient comme le vent entre
simple brise et tourbillon que se
manifestent lé influence de la lune est
leur fantaisie naturel devient
trépidante lots dessins joyeusement de
la montagne le ruisseau bouillonne
tout paraît gay vivant dynamique le
moindre mouvement se transforme en
agitation
l'air mutable éléments des gémeaux est
un air de mobilité de diffusion c'est
l'ère de la respiration par lequel nous
entrons en contact étroit avec le monde
extérieur et que nous partageons avec
les êtres qui nous entoure chaque
créature inspire et expire heller qui
porte la voix est synonyme d'échangés de
contact avec les autres les mains elle
aussi correspondent à ce besoin de
sensations et de motilité les mains qui
se frôlent les mains qui s'agrippent
inspirer expirer dans la mythologie
mercure qui régit les gémeaux et est le
messager des dieux mercure qui
personnifie la communication gouverne
également la vierge
la vierge signe de terre comme le
taureau fixe et le capricorne cardinal
avec sa gerbe à la main elle symbolise
le signe de terre mutable sur les sols
arides
seuls peuvent prendre racine quelques
plantes particulièrement robuste la
simplicité une adaptation valeurs
essentielles c'est ce que propose la
terre vierge infertiles c'est une terre
en perpétuelle mutation
inlassablement remodelé au gré des vents
de nouvelles dunes apparaissent
s'accrochant pas la moindre aspérité
pour en épouser la forme signe de terre
la vierge de mercure est attaché au
concret à la logique et au sens des
réalités
de même l'eau et le vent ronge la pierre
la décompose la mort celle pour la
remodeler ensuite fractionné pour mieux
rebâtir c'est la vocation de la vierge
elle a le don de l'analyse celui de
concrétiser l'informel
mais les maîtres mots sont méthode et
organisation tout s'imbrique tout
s'emboîte l'infatigable bâtisseurs
développe son instinct créateur est une
grande puissance de travail
enraciné dans le présent ils n'acceptent
le changement que si le projet
d'envergure et que s'il est sûr de le
voir aboutir
non
nous
il
là où l'homme se fixe ils cultivent la
terre qui lui fournira l'essentiel de sa
nourriture
l'épi est le symbole de la vierge
arrivé à maturité les céréales elles
aussi sont égrainés transformé pour
fournir à notre corps ces éléments
vitaux gouverné par mercure les gémeaux
et les vierges sont des signes mutable
un troisième est le sagittaire
c'est un signe de feu le feu le plus
actif le feu qui se propage les flammes
serpente s'agite change constamment de
forme
le feu s'amplifie se déploie dévore son
environnement
rien n'échappe au fou du sagittaire
enthousiaste passionné plein de tonus et
de vitalité
c'est le feu de la passion l'amour de la
chasse ou un goût parfois immodéré de
l'aventuré
les étincelles qui jaillissent répandent
lincendie le sagittaire se nourrit de la
diversité des individus des pays et des
cultures mais l'élément feu trouve aussi
ses correspondants dans d'autres grands
cycles naturels
ainsi celui de la germination les
semences parcours tels aussi l'espace
pour sont allés germé loin de leur lieu
d'origine
une autre forme de souffle divin qui
fertilisent la terre
planant au dessus des domaines humains
jupiter pour les romains c'est le roi
des dieux le dieu suprême jupiter le
dieu qui veille à la bonne ordonnance du
monde à l'harmonie de sa croissance
le sagittaire signe d'ordre de
permanence dans la hiérarchie des choses
signe de maturité celle du fruit dans la
phase épanouie de son développement
naît d'une graine ou d'un pépin qui
croient fleury et enfin mûri pour être
cueillies où se régénérer dans une
nouvelle germination la loi immuable de
la nature celle du perpétuel
recommencement
les eaux du ciel arrosez transfigure
lempire terrestre de jupiter
jupiter qui régit aussi le quatrième des
signes mutable celui de l'eau
n'ont plus l'eau courante des rivières
ni celle qui stagne mais celle des
océans et celle aussi de la pluie et de
la rosée
les poissons symbolise bien logiquement
ce dernier signe
sur le zodiaque ils font vis-à-vis à la
vierge
la vierge la terre mutable la terre
baignée par les eaux mutable des
poissons
outre jupiter neptune le dieu de la mer
gouverne les poissons avec son trident
les vagues car est inlassablement le
rivage un flot sans cesse renouvelée
mais jamais pareil à lui-même
la mère rejoint le ciel lorsque ces eaux
s'évapore s'élève en gouttelettes
minuscule pour aller former par dessus
la terre un autre océan un océan de
nuages
e
où
on
dans leur immense voyage ils prennent
des formes fantastiques auxquels nos
pensées à 6000 nos langues heure où nos
espoirs
nous
la balance venus aérienne apparente aux
nuages neptunia ses rêves romantiques
nos visions inspirent nos sentiments
peigne notre caractère
tous ces principes symbolique se
combinent à l'infini pour constituer les
face à d'innombrables de nos différentes
personnalités des nuages s'accroche au
flanc des montagnes les froideurs
saturnienne les entraîne dans la
pesanteur terrestre
il se traîne jusqu'aux frontières de la
terre pour se cristalliser en neige
les hommes se sont obscurément
tributaire de lois qui régissent
l'ensemble de l'univers mais qui reste
pour eux aussi complexe qu'un caractère
neptunia
l'homme manque encore de cette
connaissance intuitive de cette pré
science du changement que possède uranus
la persévérance saturnienne doit nous
pousser à tirer de nouvelles leçons de
nos connaissances acquises sur les
formes et les structures de la matière
il nous faut chercher surtout les
chemins que nous ouvre la connaissance
la vérité le fruit de la sagesse
jupitérienne est difficile à trouver ça
qu'elle doit être un à sable et rien ne
doit la décourager
cette vérité repose peut-être au plus
profond de nous mêmes
des poissons aux scorpions nous avons
fait le tour des 12 signes du zodiaque
nous y avons pris conscience de la force
martienne qui nous permet de nous
dépasser et aussi le charme vénusien qui
adoucit notre existence
nous discernons fugitivement les mille
et une facettes de l'existence passons
rapidement de l'une à l'autre nos idéaux
voltige dans l'air que soufflent les
gémeaux et viennent parfois se fracasser
sur terre en poussière de mélancolie et
nous nous reprenons aussitôt à méditer
sur les êtres et les choses comme la
planète
l'addition de nos contradictions forme
un tout
notre gracq terre est composé d'une
infinité d'éléments traduisible en
images
fouineur renfermé
solidaires sombre chaleureux ensoleillé
renfermé froid
des primes et mélancolique
ouvert au monde
notre venus divine artistes nous invite
à l' équilibre et occulte de l'harmonie
aux couleurs de la balance
c'est d'elle que nous viendra peut-être
l'intuition d'une certaine perfection
qu'est ce que la beauté à l'état pur et
d'où nous vient ce besoin irrésistible
de le découvrir un jour